بينما تستمر الأنظمة الغذائية النباتية والنباتية
في اكتساب شعبية ، تشير دراسة جديدة
من المجلة الطبية BMJ إلى أن
أولئك الذين لا يأكلون اللحوم قد يكونون
أكثر عرضة للإصابة بالسكتة الدماغية من أولئك
الذين أجروا البحث الذي أجري من خلال تتبع
ما يقرب من 50000 شخص على مدى
ما يقرب من شخصين.  وجدت عقودًا أن
النباتيين والنباتيين
معرضون لخطر الإصابة بالسكتة الدماغية بنسبة 20٪ أعلى من أولئك الذين يتناولون اللحوم ،
ولا سيما السكتة الدماغية غير المنتظمة عندما
ينزف الدم من الشريان إلى
الدماغ ، وهذا يترجم إلى ثلاث
حالات أخرى من السكتة الدماغية لكل 1000 شخص خلال
فترة 10 سنوات.  تُظهر الدراسة نفسها أيضًا
أن الاستغناء عن اللحوم
يرتبط بانخفاض خطر الإصابة بأمراض القلب
التاجية بنسبة 22 في المائة ، ومن غير الواضح سبب
اكتشاف البحث أن ارتفاع
خطر الإصابة بالسكتة الدماغية لدى النباتيين بالنسبة لأولئك الذين
أجروا الدراسة يشير إلى مستويات منخفضة جدًا من
الكوليسترول أو مستويات منخفضة جدًا من
العناصر الغذائية مثل فيتامين ب 12  ومع ذلك ،
أشار التقرير إلى الصحة العامة
للنباتيين مقارنة بأكل اللحوم
في الدقيقة الصحية اليوم أنا ميريديث وود